Google Cloud updates our developer
conference IO was last week and if you
missed any of the announcements you can
catch up on the blog or watch the
recorded sessions now in public preview
bigquery differential privacy an
anonymization technique that limits the
personal information that is revealed by
an output check out the blog for more
details and use cases the data cloud and
AI Summit is Google Cloud's Global event
that showcases the latest Innovations
and how customers are transforming their
businesses and if you missed our third
annual event be sure to catch up on the
blog get more on all these stories at
the links below thanks for watching this
episode of